il aimait les autres et il a vécu dans
la solitude
il rêvait d'un foyer et il a connu
l'asile psychiatrique
il est mais il aurait tout aimé et il
est mort à 37 ans le reste dans la
course aux rafales de cette existence
torturé est une réédition misérables est
géniale de la lutte de jacob avec l'ange
et l'orge
c'est la lumière c'était le personnage
principal de ce récit ne la perdez pas
de vue vous la verrez apparaître tout
d'abord furtivement brillante au fond
des ténèbres comme une étoile confuses
puis vous la verrez grandir éblouir le
tableau est opérée sur elle même une
espèce d'orientation accélérée qui
finira par entraîner le paysage le ciel
et la terre et la mer et tourner seul et
l'esprit douloureux du peintre lui même
dans son irrésistible giration pauvre
jacob
pour vincent
c'est lui qui va vous raconter sa propre
histoire dans les admirables lettre aux
frères parfaitement fraternel que la
providence lui avait donné et qui vivra
assez pour voir arriver traîne hard la
gloire que la société bourgeoise de la
belle époque envoyaient parfois déposé 7
condoléances chiffrées sur la tombe des
artistes qu'elle avait laissé mourir
seuls avec leur immense désir de
communion écoutez le
théo si tu peux m'envoyer quelque chose
ne fut-ce que cinq francs ne manquent
pas il y aura encore dix jours jusqu'à
la fin du mois et je n'ai presque plus
rien pour vivre
et
mon numéro suivant les numéros 15 du
catalogue tableau de vincent van gogh
champs de coquelicots
enfin en 1890 à auvers produit est
décrit dans le catalogue d'arbres de la
fagne sous le numéro 7 155
nous allons commencer par 5 millions de
francs 5 millions de francs 5 millions
500 mille familles on s'informe i 6
millions 6 millions 500 mille ici au
premier en sept millions personnes pour
plus de 7 millions 7 millions 500 mille
8 millions perçoivent de dhimmi rue nain
ce miroir à 9 millions 10 millions
missiaen la vendit mignon 11 millions et
demi en ont remis en 12 min sur l'a12
mis en personne les trois là bas 14 15
16 17 et eefje en avant dit c'est dit
c'est ici en avant dix sept 17 me en
personne 17 17 millions 500 mille 10 7
me ont fait preuve
j'ai assez longtemps et faune et des
dessins sont beaucoup avancé mais depuis
quelques temps ça va mieux il s'agit
pour moi d'apprendre à bien dessiné une
fois cela obtenu je ferai de bonnes
choses n'importe où et le borinage est
aussi pittoresques que le vieux venise
ou l'arabie la bretagne
peut-être qu verra encore que moi aussi
je suis un travailleur mais le chemin
est étroit
l'apport des t3 et il y en a peu qui la
trouve
non
décembre 1883 moins cher théo fille
réussit à obtenir la permission de papa
de m'installer ici au presbytère je me
suis déjà établi provisoirement dans cet
atelier où j'espère avancer un peu
depuis mon arrivée ici il ne s'est pas
passé un jour sans que je n'ai travaillé
parmi les tisserands où les paysans du
matin au soir
e
j'ai voulu exprimer
que les mains de ces pauvres gens qui
prennent leurs pommes de terre du plat à
la lueur d'une lampe sont les mêmes qui
ont baissé chez la terre ces tableaux
par le don de travail manuel et de la
façon honnête dont ils ont gagné leur
nourriture
e
il se pourrait bien qu'un jour ce
tableau se révèle être un vrai tableau
de vie de paysan
quant à moi je suis convaincu qu'il en
est ainsi
mais il y a des gens qui préfèrent voir
les paysans d'une façon romantique qu'on
les laisse faire
blanchir théo tu ne m'en veut pas d'être
venu à paris sans te prévenir
j'ai temps réfléchi et je crois que de
cette manière nous gagnerons du temps
je tâcherai de te faire encore des
tableaux car je suis tout à fait
tranquille
quant à mon travail je voudrais surtout
d'être moins à charge et cela n'est pas
impossible dorénavant car j'espère faire
de tels progrès que tu puisses hardiment
montrer ce que j'ai fait santes
compromettre
tout en étant chagrinés que les dépens à
ce soit forte et les tableaux et nos
valeurs
je ne désespère pas de la réussite de
cette entreprise de faire un long voyage
à arles dans le midi
je suis dans une rage de travail et j'ai
déjà fait diverger
je crois qu'après tout l'avenir de l'art
nouveau est dans le midi seulement c'est
une mauvaise politique d'y rester seul
lorsque deux ou trois pourraient céder à
vivre un peu
je souhaiterais pouvoir fonder un
pied-à-terre qui en cas d'erreur demain
pourrait servir à mettre au vert les
pauvres chevaux de fiacre de paris qui
sont soi même mais nos amis les
impressionnistes pauvres celle où l aile
droite de cette construction
j'ai écrit à gauguin que je regrettais
que nous travaillons si loin l'un de
l'autre et que c'était dommage que
plusieurs peintres ne se refuse pas
réunies pour une campagne ans
mon cher théo je t'écris de sainte-marie
au bord de la méditerranée
la méditerranée à une couleur de poisson
c'est à dire changeantes
on ne sait pas toujours si sévère ou
biolay ou bleu car la seconde après le
reflet après une tête de rose et grise
de retour à arles
je travaille d'après un modèle un
facteur en uniforme bleu grosse figure
barbue dre socratique
le changement que j'essaierai de faire
dans mes tableaux serait de peindre un
plus grand nombre de portraits
la question de peindre des scènes nous
est fait de nuit sur place à la nuit
même m'intéresse énormément dans mon
café de nuit
je cherchais exprimé avec le rouge est
levée et terrible patients humaine le
café comme un endroit où l'on peut se
ruiner devenir fou
commettre des crimes
il faudrait hardiment exagérée des
effets que produisent les couleurs par
leur accord ou leur désaccord
le dessin la couleur juste n'est peut
être pas l'essentiel qu'il faut
rechercher car le reflet de la réalité
dans le miroir si c'était possible de le
fixer avec toutes ces couleurs ne serait
aucunement un tableau tout au plus une
photographie alors seulement je ressens
la vie lorsque je travaille intensément
jamais je n'ai eu une telle chance ici
la nature est extraordinairement belle
mais ma couleur ma toile la bourse sont
épuisés complètement de lundi à jeudi
je n'ai fait que deux repas
l'argent que tu me donnes
et que d'ailleurs je te demande plus que
jamais je te le rendrait en travail mais
laisse moi travailler tant que ça ne
soit pas absolument impossible je n'y
peux rien si mes tableaux ne se vendent
pas le jour viendra cependant où l'on
verra que cela vaut plus que le prix de
la couleur et de ma vie on sommes très
maigre que nous y mettons
gauguin est arrivé en bonne santé nous
causons beaucoup de delacroix membranes
et cetera la discussion et d'une
électricité excessivement nous en
sortons parfois à la dette
fatigué comme une batterie électrique
après la décharge
ouais
je t'écris de l'hôpital
en pleine possession de ma présence
d'esprit
et non pas comme un fou mais en frères
que tu connais près de 80 personnes ont
adressé au maire une adresse me
désignant comme un homme pas digne de
vivre en liberté
si en effet je me suis fait une blessure
à moi même
on n'avait pourtant pas fait à ces gens
là à la fin du mois je désirerais aller
à l'hospice de serre émis je me sens
incapable de reprendre un nouvel atelier
et d'y rester seul couac ici il y ait
quelques malades fort grave
la peur l'horreur que j'avais auparavant
de la folie c'est déjà beaucoup adouci
en travaillant dehors ils viennent me
voir et je vous assure qu'ils sont plus
polis
plus discret pour me laisser tranquille
que par exemple des bons citoyens
d'arles
je lutte de toute mon énergie pour
maîtriser mon travail me disant que si
je gagne cela sera le meilleur
paratonnerre contre la maladie
ans
l'entourage ici commence à me peser plus
que je ne saurais l'exprimer il me faut
de l'air je me sens un bis mais d'ennui
et de chagrin
si une attaque revient je persiste à
vouloir essayer un changement de climat
est retourné dans le bar voici ce que tu
pourrais écrire un de ces jours à notre
ami le docteur gachet à auvers mon frère
désirant beaucoup faire votre
connaissance
j'espère que vous prouviez bien qu'il
passe quelques semaines dans votre
village où il viendra faire des études
au vert est décidément fort beau
tellement que je crois que ce sera plus
avantageux de travailler que de ne pas
travailler
le docteur gachet dis que je vais tout à
fait bien il est fanatique pour son
portrait auquel je travaille oui je
cherche à faire aussi bien que je peux
mais je ne te cache pas que je n'ose
guère y compter
d'avoir toujours la santé nécessaires
les perspectives s'assombrissent
je ne vois pas l'avenir heureux du tout
ma vie à moi aussi attaquer à la racine
mais montrent pas aussi est chancelant
le pinceau ne tombant presque des mains
j'ai encore peint trois grandes toiles
et je ne me suis pas gêné pour chercher
à exprimer de la tristesse de la
solitude extrême
je pourrais peut-être écrire sur bien
des choses mais d'abord l'envié m'en a
tellement passé
j'en ressors l'inutilité vraiment nous
pouvons faire parler que nos tableaux un
coup de pistolet a mis fin au combat
laborieusement comme s'il manquait
encore des tristesses à ce désespoir
presqu'en même temps et au même âge dans
la même détresse
moore est un autre génie arthur rimbaud
qui semblait avoir écrit pour lui même
et pour le grand artiste qu'il ne
connaissait pas sévère étrangement
chrétiens j'étends fait patients ce
qu'est la faim j'oublie crainte des
souffrances aux cieux sont partis